cette histoire que je vais raconter elle
a commencé pour moi il ya exactement 12
ans c'était au moment où je finissais
mes études d'architecturé et bien sûr
j'avais choisi tunis et le lac de tunis
pour pour un objet qui qui qui avait
pour vocation c'est un objet flottant
sur le lac de tunis qui avait pour
vocation de rendre publics des choses
qui ne l'étaient plus des choses qui est
qui et qui était en train de ne plus le
devenir la ville qui était en train
d'échapper de nous échapper complètement
et quand j'ai présenté ce quand j'avais
présenté ce projet là il y avait
quelqu'un un membre du jury qui
s'appelait qui s'appelle marc barani
rallier ce que vous êtes en train de
faire est une guérilla urbaine non
violence bien sûr une guérilla urbaine
qui a pour vocation de devenir les
choses d'une manière indirecte mais
qu'il est dit et aujourd'hui si je suis
là c'est parce que donc nous ans après
les choses m'ont la vie on aide les gens
là où ils ne sont pas là où il n'avait
pas prévu d'aller mais on n'oublie pas
des choses et si je suis là c'est un peu
pour vous engager aussi dans cette
grille parce que c'est important parce
que la vie c'est important c'est la
ville c'est nous mêmes c'est un peu la
terre c'est important la terre c'est
précieux
c'est une rareté et c'est un peu une
action c'est aussi précieux à l'être
humain que le corps la terre donc voila
se prendre tous donc j'ai appelé tounes
parce que et savez quand vous avez vu
recul avec tous parce que tunis c'est
pour tous et par tous et surtout surtout
vous allez voir par tous voilà tunis
j'espère que vous reconnaissez avec
l'énorme étendue d'eau qui est le lac de
tunis et qui voit la ville
méditerranéenne sans vraiment l'être
parce que il y a le lac entre la vie et
l'eau voilà ce qu'a été tunis depuis
maintenant neuf siècles elle a évolué ce
bout de cette petite graine rouge
magnifique green rouge que vous voyez là
c'est tunis c'est la médina et neuf
siècles jusqu'aux portes du xxème siècle
c'était ça rien d'autre que ça jusqu'à
ce que voilà ce qui va se passer
une ville coloniale va venir d'accord
doublé tunis
ça veut dire que ce qu'on va faire c'est
une colonisation tunisie qui s'appelle
un protectorat ça veut dire que le
pouvoir va se dédoubler et avec un
pouvoir qui se dédoublent la vie de ceux
des doubles aussi est ce qui va se
passer sans beaucoup réfléchir d'accord
le bey de tunis va céder des terrains
marécageux qui sont entre encore une
fois qu'ils sont eux qui sont les
terrains qui font avancer la ville vers
l'eau et on va venir coller un modèle le
plus basique du monde un modèle
quadrillé un modèle qu'on ignore et
quand quand l'ex comme il est et en des
boucles et ce modèle d'accord c'est la
ville coloniale dans son essence la plus
totale ça veut dire qu'elle a en gros
deux buts premier but d'être jolie pour
attirer en valais nommé comme ils sont
des colons pour venir s'installer je lis
et adapté à un modèle qui qu'il est
qu'ils connaissent déjà deuxième but
c'est un but d'extraction ça veut dire
tout et c'est ce qui va faire donc le
premier but va faire ce que cherche et
bourguiba et la promenade de la marine
c'est joli c'est pittoresque
on a envie de venir et un théâtre venez
venez vous installer à tunis deuxième
but c'est l'extraction ces douloureuses
l'extraction des richesses entière d'un
pays en prend en acheminant en transport
et en achemine et c'est ce qui a causé
le ce qui est le sud de tunis
aujourd'hui ça veut pas dire que c'est
mauvais aujourd'hui c'est joli c'est à
nous maintenant
mais c'est ce qu'une ville coloniale et
c'est pas un constat malheureusement
douloureux ce qui va se passer après à
la colonisation de cons en vérité en
vérité de ce schéma double qui en train
de s'étirer vers le nord et vers le suit
mais on va aussi
hérité d'une situation où personne
absolument personne n'a réfléchi
personne ne sait faire la ville
personnes qu'est ce qu'on va faire
comment on a fait avant rien du tout il
ya quelqu'un qui a dessiné des plans à
paris où je ne fais ou dans n'importe
quelle ville française en a produit une
ville qui a des loyautés autre qui est
là pour une terre qui n'est pas qui est
qui et qui dans son sens d'être n'est
pas la déloyauté autres tels que la
terre sur laquelle elle est comment on
va faire on n'a pas d'urbanistes on n'a
pas d'architecte on n'a personne pour
réfléchir et vous même un d'accord le
premier organisme de tunisie bourguiba
que va faire bourguiba le grand
nettoyage des gourbis fication et on
construit vite à bon marché ont
construit le limbe le pôle important
c'est de construire construire et faire
la ville à n'importe quel prix dans un
progressisme dans la précipitation et
dans un dans une idée sans référence
juste d'y aller ce qui va se passer
c'est après encore jusque dans les
années 80 une explosion une explosion
urbaine on va tout prendre tout prendre
et l'hégémonie si une gourmandise
incroyable la ville prend tous d'accord
bon malheureusement là c'est la carte
d'aujourd'hui donc dans les années 80
c'était quand même un peu loin
maintenant on a vraiment tout prix qu'on
a tous pris une autre date
une autre date qui est d'une extrême
importance pour la ville que on a
peut-être oublié cette date la baie mais
je vous assure que tunis en rappel à
cette adresse et 1983 en 1983 un deal va
avoir lieu d'accord parce que dans le
processus d'assainissement de la ville
bourguiba avait dit on va assécher le
lac le lac devient une nuisance en
valais à sécher dans ce processus
d'assécher le lac pour encore prendre de
la place de l'espace dans ce processus
là le lac le dans le var va devenir une
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez vous
êtes trop jeune pour vous en vous en
rappeler mais va devenir quelque chose
d'horrible qui va sentir mauvais cru
être la plus grande nuisance de tunis
pendant longtemps et donc là il fallait
faire que
ce quelque chose d'accord le deal il est
de ramener les champions du monde en la
matière on les travaux hydrauliques qui
sont hollandais et
et le dis c'est que on pouvait pas les
payer bien sûr karim transaction
d'accord les terrains dont contre le
prix de l'assainissement du lac vous
prenez les terrains gagnés
ça veut dire que il va y avoir je ne
sais pas si vous vous souvenez aussi et
avait il ya eu un moment dans les années
80 en tunisie une pub qui tournait en
boucle et qu'ils aient des brian un fil
vous avez enseigné le lac et vous
commencez mais qui êtes-vous d'accord
ces terrains-là échappe complètement à
l'état échappe complètement au public
nous est déjà complètement
or on ne parle pas de deux kilomètres
carrés on ne parle pas d'un tard on
parle ça la gemmi aussi l'aéroport en
rouge parce que c'est ce qui risque
d'arriver on parle d'un espace énorme
qui est le prochain poumon de tunis
après avoir explosé littéralement tunis
a besoin d'un poumon à l'intérieur et
ces terrains là sans ce moment là et on
ne peut pas c'est pas possible de les
laisser échapper au temps à nous ça veut
dire qu'encore une fois ce qui va être
fait si si ces terres là échappe encore
une fois est-ce que à un autre droit de
regard
si ces terres là échappe encore une fois
au fait qu' on ne les maîtrisent pas
c'est le même schéma qu'ici c'est
exactement le même schéma qui va avoir
lieu ici ça veut dire que c'est ce sens
c'est un plan qui est fait ailleurs
d'accord je ne sais pas où tous en a vu
c'est ces images surréalistes de ville
je ne sais plus dans quel dans quel
bureau d'architectes du duduk je ne sais
pas de rock ou du golfe ou d'asie
d'accord qui nous dessine des vieux où
il n'y a rien de public où ils vont
encore oublié de tous toutes sortes de
mixité où ils vont encore oublié des
bibliothèques
ils vont encore oublié des terrains de
jeux pour les enfants où ils vont encore
oublié le
d'étranges les moyens de transport où
ils vont encore oublié les trottoirs
parce qu'aujourd'hui ans vit dans des
villes sans trottoir où ils vont encore
oublié les peaux les les espaces verts
ce qui va se passer c'est que au lieu
d'un parc ils mettront en golf au lieu
d'un terrain de jeu vraiment ils vont
mettre un parc d'attraction disneyland
encore pour ou en paye pour aller et on
ne bouge à chaque fois qu'on perd bouger
avec un enfant en dehors on doit payer
des tickets pour au lieu d'une
bibliothèque qui vont mettre des molles
ou des choses un personnel et 7 nuits et
cet espace là va échapper échapper non
seulement à l'état mais en plus le pire
le pire ici des chats palette des
échappés au citoyen c'est pas possible
ce n'est pas possible que des tunisiens
ou autres que des tunisiens construit
sur notre terre parce que c'est notre
terre la terre c'est précieux
encore une fois il suffit de lire de
d'écouter ceux qui ont été prises privés
ceux qui ne l'ont pas pour savoir que
vivre sans terre c'est être malade c'est
vivre malade c'est comme vivre
amputé de quelque chose faut lire
mahmoud darwish pour comprendre que que
la terre c'est le corps et nous d'accord
céder la terre c'est comme céder une
partie de son corps et se désengager de
ce combat là se désengager donné son
droit de regard
le cd comme ça à 1 à des gens qui
sortent d'accord sur internet les images
se réalise qu'il ait laissé faire à ce
point c'est très grave c'est insulter
son prochain c'est insulter insulté son
enfant son propre enfant et insulté là
d'où l'on vient on ne vient pas de rien
finalement tu dises quand on lit
l'histoire d'accord à part à part au
xvième siècle voilà à quoi il ya eu des
épidémies c'était vraiment horrible à
cette ville-là par le pouvoir de la
prise providence peut être a échappé au
pire
et si elle a échappé au pire toujours
malgré tout d'accord rien qui c'était
horrible la dictature a été horrible
bourguiba a été horrible
et benali a été horrible aussi avec la
ville avec la ville je vous voir réagir
et oui oui on a tous été cruel avec la
ville mais à chaque fois grâce à mon
grâce à certaines personnes grâce aux
volontés de certaines personnes
on a échappé au pire et pour échapper au
pire
il faut que l'avenir de tunis pour
qu'ils soient meilleurs il faut qu'il
soit pour tous et par tous on ne peut
pas laisser nos terrains nous échapper à
ce point parce que c'est exactement la
même chose que les c'est comme si on
était en train de laisser notre propre
corps nous échapper à ce qu'on voit la
remercie normal